although it looks like a dance this is
actually a spider murmur acnes one
acharya is a jumping spider which has
evolved its ant-like appearance as a
clever ruse to evade predators similar
evolutionary adaptations have been found
in the past such as butterflies that
look like they're less tasty cousins and
beetles that look like scary wasps
researchers looked at these tiny
arachnids with a high-speed camera and
they found the spiders not only look
like ants but they walk like dance to
when marching along the spider walks in
a winding wave motion which appears the
potential predators as an ant following
a trail
it was previously thought these ant like
spiders don't use their front legs at
all when walking instead raising them up
as pantomime antennae this new research
shows that when the viewed and
slow-motion spiders move using all eight
legs only raising the front ones
whenever they take a pause these pauses
are our other piece of mimicry the
stuffs are consistently spaced out and
timed long enough to nail the illusion
in most species of jumping spiders
raising the four limbs is a sign of
aggression so in the future researchers
would like to see if other spiders are
full do they see a threatening spider or
just another ant
you
you